COUNCIL OF MINISTERS
LEGISLATES ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL GOVERNMENTS
The councils are the main legislative
bodies of the European Union.
It is, kind of,
the 27 Member States' house.
It is where ministers
from each country meet.
The Council of Ministers
meets in various formations.
In each case, the ministers responsible
for specific fields take part.
When a compromise is made, on the
basis of a proposal from the Commission,
we will negotiate
with the European Parliament.
Our role, my role as
President of the Council,
is more of a facilitator, a mediator.
Our aim is to reach a consensus.
It is a challenge.
You are chairing a meeting
in another language
and some of the issues that we are
debating are of a very complex nature.
The most difficult part is what is
required before you sit at the table,
so good preparation is essential.
You have personal contact
with each member of the Council.
Knowing the background
of each one's position is important.
So you get to know
the "whys" and the "whats".
I think it is very important
that you hear what other people say.
That you really listen.
Not just give them the floor and
say thank you, but you really listen.
Understanding the others' position
is a key element in reaching decisions
on a European level.
There has been a lot of fuss and worry
and debate about Europe in general,
but Europe is also working.
We can take decisions.
We can throw light on the way
some financial products are traded.
We can make sure that we handle
a foreign policy situation.
We can deal with
farming and agriculture,
environment and climate,
energy efficiency.
We take decisions. This will be
better for the citizens in the future.
Because it is important that the Union
works regardless of the crisis,
regardless of the debates about
Europe's global standing.